brennon Oh bro it's 2018 dude happy new
dude last time I saw you
yeah I think was last year it was 2000
2017 this profiteering really last year
Brennan did you did you just grab it by
the horns and ride it did you slide in
or you ride it though 2018 gonna be
exactly like doing seven no idea it's
gonna be lit oh man
till a teens not to be game changers
this is the year that I that I start
working up now I do that all right this
is no this is thank you what's your news
I really I gear down yeah and I do
stand-up least twice a week do that now
you know this is the years the year that
we knock out at least two podcasts a
week I do third for this is the you got
to come up with something give me
something this year are you a drug habit
I go opposite she's the year I'm a
little more kind and I listen more at
some guys I've never I've never had some
guy who couch top tells girl goes you
don't mind you use resolution was she
was like as read more want to read well
dope
well don't set that goal too high my man
you could [ __ ] read here if you watch
generally on yeah I was asleep by 11:00
what's Copa yeah went to scopa went
there with the fam the cool thing I get
that seeing a picture of it they're like
we know your big Campari guy so you know
what Campari collectors all yearned for
and like what that all boom there's the
I guess one year 1975 5 or 74 they made
a white bottle like a white label they
gave me that that was cool
that's why the highlight - they give it
to you cuz scope has old vintage we came
from they got it from there Wow from the
what's that called now what it taste
speakeasy anything it's doesn't taste as
it's just it's different it's still nice
I just did a little shot I'm saving that
bad boy I went to watch the fights at
champs on New Year's no no I'm when I
fight with the the on Saturday yeah well
my my
my dad am I my nephew wanted to watch
University of Miami plays you're in a
Mexico correct I was no yeah I was in
Cancun everybody I was in Concord and I
go and I I say you know what this guy I
talked to said there's one place called
a distill distill area and it's very
authentic Mexico and they're Americans
there but if you know what to order and
I go bring me the order UFC fights
I'm confused you're presenting food yes
look like so I'm there to do both so I
get there and I realize the fights are
not gonna start yet we get there early
and they do have the fights correct
alone so I I go I'm not eating this food
at a sports bar called champs by the way
everybody got sick everybody got sick
everybody I'll get to that
is it champs like the USA sure is sure
is yes tandem yep so I go nope take me
right down the way I can see it this
theory I go there I eat and I get there
and I go well um and the driver is just
sitting there and he works for the hotel
and he goes okay how long and I go are
you hungry
and he goes a little bit I go well come
on in man I'll get you you know I
figured would sit at the bar now we got
a table with a candle you hit me I don't
he doesn't speak English very well I
don't know the guy it sure is and there
we are having a romantic dinner for two
of the night though it was outstanding
Mexican food like like like a fresh
authentic oh I think Waccamaw Linnell
sick your chance I'm drinking I buy him
a like a shot of tequila Jose Cuervo
reservoir laughs I mean yeah yeah but he
doesn't you know he drink he didn't have
a lot of money so he he drinks when he
drinks tequila he's gonna down it
this [ __ ] is sipping tequila he goes
come on it's expensive you know I don't
know bro you got a sip and tell no
drinks get really [ __ ] tequila huh
anyway that was romantic
watch the fight you guys did see the
fights they're wise they had them
because it wasn't like a huge paper now
but Mexico is all about the fights man
they're big in it but you know what I'm
in Mexico and I know like Costa Rica
Brazil they don't have to pay for
pay-per-view they don't they don't the
pay-per-view is different they're mostly
it's free yeah that's right yeah
actually it's free there yeah yeah just
trying to grow the sports and their
brother-in-law decided to get himself a
little chicken wrap now when you're
Mexico don't get a chicken wrap here's
why cuz they put mayo on that chicken
wrap and they got lettuce on they do
that here - yeah but this is America and
there's something about Mexico where the
water or something they still haven't
quite one [ __ ] to get water still yeah
and mom one I tell you that he was
shaking and his his stomach was like
late was AG alien food poisoning
yeah my sister was like I can't go in
there just last a year though army like
today day correct one day your current
it is hell for it's hell for a day you
know bite down hell for a photo your
[ __ ] out yellow your lungs and all I
kept saying was I'm never come back here
good yeah I'm going to Hawaii hate it
you never want to eat that [ __ ]
again ever
no dude I was I had a little head we're
both sick I was sick for tonight when
you left the sick for dinner was sick
and then right when you left my dad came
in town right when he got him like I
don't feel good man they just had the
worst head cold for about four days yeah
I was good though I had the flu for ten
days do you are one we're I'm rolling I
threw up after it was the all downhill
from there all downhill from all did I
knew it would be because you tell me how
to scratchy throat and I was like
something's up
his body's well you know what happens we
burn then you get time off and when you
get time off your body goes oh you guys
have you got nine days off down we're
gonna force you to [ __ ] oh yeah we're
gonna force you to shut down gonna shut
the gates up how about I give you a flu
you're gonna sweat through for sure
tonight and you're gonna have a coffee
you're gonna hack up the craziest [ __ ]
in the world and then you're gonna have
to get on antibiotics because you it's
turning into my guys I want to stop I'll
keep having around too me too
doctor was like she just said that yeah
you got it you gotta get on it was kind
of nice though la shuts down there's
much work to do I did stand-up with Joe
at the ice house it's not it yeah and I
shut it down shut down was Tiger to tell
you Disneyland
okay how was that a mom scene we got
there at UH we left the house at 7 a.m.
got their shoes the gates open went on
all the rides were talking get the [ __ ]
out it's very so busy because now it's
the terse time yes so [ __ ] busy yeah
you get in early and you get out in an
hour brother in and out Papa's jobs in
town what's the fights had taught over
yeah weird some food oh and then then
yesterday got my papa
tickets well Joe stepdad he's a Highway
Patrol guy he's like the head Highway
Patrol guy works in Pasadena so he does
all the stuff for the Rose Bowl so he's
going you guys want tickets like oh yeah
he's talking about the parade starts at
8 a.m. of course my dad goes stop [ __ ]
my dad lights up like a Christmas tree
he goes really and I went you should for
sure go to that she has to leave at 6
a.m. takes an uber at 6 a.m. with my
stepmom that's amazing they go sit
through the entire parade that starts at
8 a.m. goes all the way to 1 and then
the game starts at 2 that's that's
actually amazing so they went from
brought watching the parade for about
four hours straight to the Rose ball
watch the game that went into double
overtime I heard another four hours
that's amazing back to home at nine
o'clock exhausted yeah that's time of
their lives though really yeah they
loved my mother what else ball was so
guy hurt it was crazy oh my god it was
good the other games suck but my my
mother will never miss a parade she
would drag us I'm raising kids she drags
sprays the Macy's Day Parade near City
coldest [ __ ]
I'd be looking at somebody skirt because
I was that small I'd be staring right
into somebody's [ __ ] yeah and then
they'd be farting I remember this so
well I'm not having to take a [ __ ] in a
[ __ ] in one of those outdoor things
and they didn't have toilet paper and I
have used my undershirt my [ __ ] and
then I just threw those like ah there
you go it's in sync see you later greats
make no sense to me
what like out like the water I'll grab
on the [ __ ] thing you know what else
that make sense to me how many sheep
gather in New York City for the New
Year's Eve bounty like I'm watching it
you can't see [ __ ] it's a sardine pie
that you're the two gay boys in that era
you're sitting a duck fur you know
kaduche
you just chilling it yeah but you're
also a sitting duck for a little
terrorism I'm always like if this is
your estate but they won't do that cuz
that's expected right so we got that
locked down yeah they're not gonna hit
they're just too busy too many people
for me what would we it's - I don't get
it my mother loved you ever seen that
ball it's pretty small yeah it's not as
big as you think it's made of crystal
yeah yeah
care no I was asleep man huh don't care
new years my sister my daughter and my
son and the other kids swam with the
dolphins that's nice
okay khun kon corn-cake who doesn't do
it for very much
No didn't do it for me either it's so
far to when I thought ya tinkin like
yeah Porter there - yeah we're Cozumel
and you can get there they're all the
same
correct correct sir that's why do you
want to know why me over there I know
the water and why is better the food's
better
there's no Isis there's no cartels
everyone's friendlies fire the guy told
me I went to this local place and I said
oh my god their court the cartels here I
said yeah of course Cancun and that's
where like like all that areas like why
can't you can't cou not so much porta
biota is the big one I know really
that's the one way all Chiapas that's
right next door
no they're actually really far from each
other so King Koontz near Miami port of
IOT is near us so part of it - so it's
Pacific time yeah I got you that's what
I'll chop with Suns are at and they want
that port
oh well cuz they tell me that that the
cartel sugar there now here's what
here's what I got a little I got a
little dirt on it what they said was
where is that oh that's my what what
they said what they said what they said
was was kind of interesting they said
they were like well no the guys they
they come to my restaurant you go I said
you have to pay money cuz know they're
gonna tell you pay money if you're doing
if people are dealing drugs out of your
are then you're gonna pay but he said
they come in their trucks they eat and
they say thank you and they leave and I
was like oh [ __ ] you know and all the
Pens yeah you see all for much further
okay cuz Cancun's basically it's right
that's where I was right once you but
yeah straightener Havana and Mex and on
Miami and then poor voters just go over
there
it doesn't make sense go all the way to
kink it it doesn't it's all the same I
agree but you know my family on the
other side is in New York all that a we
when they go down yes so it's a beast
for you guys it's a [ __ ] what's
the middle it's got a milligram good a
port of it so where do I go on the west
side cuz I heard he's really nice the
south is apparently
you know where you want to what over
here - that's where I would just was
it's nice
oh you were there yeah I was there
that's where they the taxi driver
wouldn't drop us a mile inland because
of El Chapo Suns they because there's a
war going on yeah because they want that
port and El Chapo's sons are just wiling
out right now and so he would not drop
you I didn't want to go he right when we
got the car he warned me like I don't
wanna [ __ ] go there I'm about a mile
from here your salient oh no we're good
turn around you know what do you mean
I'll eat it though toe cheese don't need
to deal with that well she don't so I
went to this widest [ __ ] farm innate
just all white people armed yeah he took
me about 80 community whites our whites
only whites whites why it's not a
Mexican white Mexicans are good no sir
white people bought this little farm and
it's all ran by white people it's
delicious food
there's no cartel you went to our white
farm Oh tell whitey oh why why do you
only ah they were judging me cuz I'm ten
I had a good time though and you're in
your failsafe your girl's Mexican
Mexican is [ __ ] yeah you're nice again
his [ __ ] super mix yeah like Mexican
pride yeah well too much for me you know
too much I'm as Mexican as Taco Bell uh
yeah but Cancun's far as [ __ ] King tends
far as [ __ ] I don't realize that either
Ted made that trip like Oh knows we'll
go to Thailand I met some cool people my
problem was that I Albright broke out
because his immune system went down
broke out on a beautiful a beautiful
pattern of crisis Rises you got to get
cool it looks like a disease it looks
like a disease AIDS yeah when you have
the big red splash it was like Tom Hanks
just stomach as by the way so you're not
wearing shorts now you look like Tom
Hanks from Philadelphia be like towards
the end of the movie tried to cover it
up a makeup my wife goes you gotta wear
long pants naked you're gonna wear
shorts yeah she can't do we you were
sweating Cancun that's right sir I was
gonna know that guy seven days in the
pool I had to wear I had to a pool I
couldn't go there I look like an idiot
so I walked around i slunk around in in
the black with my black sure did in my
black sweats and and a t-shirt all day
never won in the water never went to the
pool cuz couldn't because it got because
I got it
jeez yeah so that I had that going for
me that was good plus a hacking cough so
things were good and oh by the way I was
sick the whole time so that was so scary
in the new year
yeah uh-huh and please understand
something else because they made the
reservations for all of us
I should room with two kids with your
two kids yeah so we had two beds
well what else hollow you're saying so
it was nice and crowded in my room kids
had a blast yeah it felt good
they did a little uh parasailing saw
Turtles saw sharp is saying when your
kids cool yeah grow toward others grow
man I've done I see a grown man who'd do
it to Beijing and your shorts right uh
Paul hi it's all [ __ ] stupid up there
and especially do better together just
like that you gay boys on this my shorts
are [ __ ] up our ass details back nuts
flop to the side my brother when you
first get back dance pretty cool then
after five minutes you like we look like
doors weave you feel like an 80s
something about having your your shorts
all bunched up just Bunch
I don't feel like such an ass then you
just up there like all right well now
look at your another 20 minutes that's
so funny
there's something about having your
shorts punched out oh it's so
uncomfortable your back is just funky
everything we're stuffing their harness
you know that's kind of like rock
climbing would be the same issue for me
a lot of times I'd be like yeah yes I
have sir like the first one I'm like
this is a mic that's cool then after the
third fourth link my daughter was just
returning down my daughter's crying the
whole time I had to take her yeah yeah I
took my pop baby in there jeez how about
the guys on zipline how about the guys
are all the hand that they tentacle toss
I'll see on the other side whoa
freighter oh no hey man you're a real
veteran OHIP lon hey hey man no hands
whoa oh man that's not double triple 15
times are dudes they put some hours on
these zip lines huh
you want to waste your life anymore and
show off in front of my family and
friends it was incredible I know is it
playing is interesting yeah man I'm at
home up in these route and up in these
tree tops whoa
we do women everywhere we went to the
because my dad instead Martin stepmama
in town went so my my dad received
bought his dream car right Portuguese
already want to poor she recently bought
it
I've had one you know I can't went for a
while and for Christmas he asked for
some portugee R Mike yeah no problem
with that I know where to get that but I
didn't want to go the dealer so we were
in rodeo and there's a porsche design
ever heard of it yes dude we went there
and I was like I'll get my dad a hat and
a belt
I'll get him that guy's like giving it
on sale - I didn't check price hat and
bell mic out whatever listen I'm not
[ __ ] I don't know [ __ ] you money I do
well but I was like Hannah Bell it's no
big deal
yeah do you check the price now how much
it's gonna kill me how much would you
how much would you pay now for Porsche
hat in the belt now it's just a Porsche
hat just don't hat black hat says
Porsche design on the side okay I'm
gonna hook my pop up for Christmas it's
made of what's that made of
standard-issue dry-fit hat and then belt
leather has a Porsche logo on the front
standard belt I'm gonna go with I'm
gonna go with 250 Jim for the belt let's
say 100 bucks a hat maybe 50 bucks are
you not what seemed out seemed like a
fair day expensive for hat though 50
yeah no sure 374 dollars no I went I
went more bottles why is this hat $115 B
now when you're up there yeah you don't
throw a Jew it thank you no no what you
do is you go you you [ __ ] me you [ __ ]
me alright I gotta get a gift though cuz
it's easier but just so you know I know
you [ __ ] me sometimes you get [ __ ]
sometimes you get punched right in your
nuts and you gotta just go alright and
then I had a free Porsche at my house
that they gave me when I bought my card
and so I gave him the bag I'm like dad
you know uh hopefully like it cuz
they're not giving those away
no no money matters but that well it's
kind of expensive he's like oh cool you
know y'all then here's this silly free
when I gave you he only rocks pretty
whatever ain't the way it goes good my
god sometimes like like I got out of I
tell you
where I was in New York and it was dark
and the guy this kind of big handsome
guy comes out his wife and his kids in
there and he's kind of a tall kind of
striking man and he goes he looks at me
and he goes you look very handsome in
those jeans and I go I'm there just like
this he's trying to [ __ ] they're just
like this meal in her jeans so I go oh
thank you and he goes where'd you get
him
and I went Calgary and he goes yep
I know I said how did you know was
because they're rich and famous right
and I went yeah I designed him oh wow he
was able to tell just by low future
that's crazy yeah I mean was it just a
fabric the fabric but we'll never know
the back I'm sure the pocket he we
didn't see the back you know I saw the
front that's why I designed to meet him
for sure tow Richard crazy yeah yeah
rich and famous anyway yeah yeah I was
crazy he designs I was like yeah that's
a dude who knows his product do my dad
yeah he dresses decent me on these
busted ass shoes and finally story I'm
like you got it you just got to get in
those shoes man we got to figure
something I'll by and we got afraid
something out here cuz I was to walk and
he's like what would he was I want like
something in between a my guys we took
me some shoes yeah we went I forget but
either way yes I just try my he's like I
like this I'm just try mine
don't worry about the price just try
them on try to mana like you're getting
those you have you simply have to get
those walk around yeah well I my wife's
gonna kill him but I'm just gonna spill
the beans cuz I got a we got a huge
fight over on the way to Cancun over
what my daughter was wearing she's gonna
get them out of me but my daughter was
wearing if you see knickers
okay that were stained and they had
holes in them and I go reflection and I
go you're putting that and my wife likes
to dress for comfort on the plane and
when I say comfort there's you know it's
like a muumuu
now hold on before you go on yeah no man
I'm being delicate man don't wanna try
what you're feeling no no let me tell
you something yeah nothing makes me more
blood-red mad don't I get on a goddamn
plane and you dressing like you're going
to bed that's at this is not the place
to down you know what
and you know what not a place you'd
address your a Catalan Amanda and so are
my kids yes and you know what I thought
has holes in my shoes where to god you
know I'm judging your family I thought
about how no I thought about how Johanna
because she's Mexican and I thought
about how a lot of Europeans would never
let their kids out ever like that Oh
Tiger does not ever ever you won't see
me outside the house she's getting so
mad at me I'm spilling beans but I don't
care it's fine because here's the thing
only one way to hang his thing yeah it
was a reflection of judgment and I felt
so American so American meanwhile I will
say this I will say this about my wife
she knows my kids my son and my daughter
lost together four pairs of shoes they
would just leave mother beat she goes
you see why I don't want to wear in the
issues I was like you know I understand
next time I'll pay for the [ __ ]
sandals though you gotta wear nice shoes
on the beach yeah I wear nice shoes on
the plane for me yeah you can't wear
shoes with the holes in them it may
here's a fireman I don't really care
that much about fashion that got them
all then what's been really bad it got
to me your kid my third and we had a
nice good at the end EDA frame yeah we
had a night you know you fight in front
of your kids you don't want them to see
you don't know yes sir like you know
yeah yeah you haven't forgets my honey
no no I'm great no they they look great
on Earth just keep doing their keeps
just gonna be great whole I can't wait
to go on this weekís I can't wait that's
that's one God we did this yeah yeah you
like quietly oh they're great
I love holes and not doing that one so
and of course my daughter picks up on it
she sighs with my wife uh-huh yeah it
was good there's a fine line though
because you off so you want respectable
shoes but nothing's worse when you see a
kid under the age [ __ ] I'm gonna say
under 21 wearing Gucci shoes oxidation
like there's a kid section at Gucci yeah
right there's a kid section there and
Joe went to go what are we doing
Tiger will never wearing that out though
there's nothing more he's not Persian so
I don't see why you're looking for Gucci
shoes from a kid not Persian is he did
he turn Chinese all of a sudden I don't
think so in those sections you do see
mostly like people from other countries
it's all these no American sir yeah and
it's for their kids yeah oh I'm sorry
dj khaled what's happening right now why
are you looking at the Gucci shoes for
kids shutter
right now do I look like a kpop star to
you why the [ __ ] are you looking for
scarves for Tiger now let me ask you
this what does what a Gucci shoes for
kids cost don't know just don't look
won't even glint and she goes I don't
know I shut down on me why going there
cuz I won't even energy love it that
will ruin this gear yeah you can't have
your kid in Gucci shoes come on now oh
come on now what it's a bum I'd lose my
[ __ ] but they want to let you want the
kids who look good look stylish
the fans are cheap concert gym there's a
cool man yeah human and cons all day in
Europe like when you see Italian
families Spanish families they are
dressed they dress well their kids are
styled even if the stuff is like casual
or sure someone has a lot of Americans
to like I won't leave the house in
sweats I don't yeah
jamming Joe Biden my David said son this
morning he was tight woke up at 4:00 I
woke up with Tiger at 5:00 Joe came down
at 7:00 she came down I'm full makeup
everything like yeah I appreciate that
we don't mess around takes discipline
yeah you know changes your mindset a
little bit like I like if you know it's
like old time like it doesn't happen but
I believe it confuse it doesn't have to
be expensive no no no just neat well put
together like if you look at movies like
you look at all movies they always
dressed like there was a discipline to
your attire
there was a discipline to when you got
on a plane you were dressed up I'm not
saying you look like a slob yeah when
did flying become this [ __ ] I'm I'm
sorry or we have 24-hour fitness why is
it morning [ __ ] sweat oh yeah
do you have a protein bar for yeah why
are you and matching sweats head-to-toe
in tennis shoes I just was sitting what
and then some people you know now the
cool thing is the tech where it's fancy
sweats
yeah like this couple were in similar
sweats yeah oh you were in the same
sweats
they love both of you this guy was a
bodybuilder he had his nope
shaved head for those little thing on
top and you know hawk yeah Mohawk at
that 35 maybe 40 his wife was her skin
what they I don't know how she was able
to stretch her skin she had a fake ass
the biggest fake tits I've ever seen man
the fakest
yeah but she had the kind of
bone structure where I was I was going
that that may have been a dude a long
time ago like it was so she had a wide
kind of wide face that you did I could
take a punch cute like boxer looks for a
wide face she liked the Indian from
predator correct sir yeah corralling
wide face I think that there's some wide
faces like really she could take a punch
way better than I could she just bear
down right kaduche yeah she had some her
cheekbones like if you said hi to her
you go from one eye to the other you
back hello you know that's just the face
of a whale shark yeah big girl further
eyes are apart they got some white icing
the big brains yeah octopus you know an
octopus can taste with each one of its
arms sure did you did yeah man I'm bald
even I've ever held one sure have
highlight of my life one eating too many
of them maybe I should being born nah
whole knocked within wine really life
changer really so cool cuz they they
wrapped in Carmel California is defeated
but octopus is different yeah butts like
eating their cousin okay but it's
different
no you're kind of backtracking right now
and that's okay no that's like alright
no there's like being a murder it's it
isn't and it is squid it's like no the
poor piece quit is Twitter the dumb Fox
who swims are not stupid their dumbest
[ __ ] and they swim in you know out there
you know what squid or whale sofa well
if well-read mode you haven't read Moby
disagree you thought what a giant squid
dude they're those exist I'm talking
about I've washed up upon this they have
and they're so big they're giant
[ __ ] like dicks
yeah they got bring up a giant squid for
us for a sec but the octopus is
octopuses my they can read your face to
see if you're angry or if you're if
you're not do you know that yeah the guy
went [ __ ] knocked was goes oh he
can't he knows you're not gonna hurt him
Oh super cooled me strong ish yeah
strong as she could have broke my heart
a fake one squids are ugly that's a big
s one on the lip
yeah I'll chop that up deep-fry it
little marination so I [ __ ] those things
are awesome though oh you know I started
watching recently and I got a question
for you be [ __ ] screen please [ __ ]
your squid chin i like squid yeah [ __ ]
it's good i like an octopus don't yeah
we all know that red
all that that kept me on are the movies
anyways I started watching recently on
Netflix El Chapo yeah so it's it's the
actual documentary on no no this is a
it's kind of like narcos but all el
chapo how we got to start how yes it's
all subtitles okay drama or a drama yeah
- how basically the el chapo story where
he came from in prison escape in his
family yeah you know what made him who
he is it's interesting story amazing
series its season there's two seasons on
Netflix El Chapo but I was watching it
you know I was watching that chapo stuff
I watch Pablo Escobar's stuff and I sing
and if they have the same opportunities
as say like white privilege mail here
would they be like a Steve Jobs or like
a head of a CEO company I don't know
obviously their work ethic pretty
[ __ ] crazy organizations like by any
means necessary yeah they're so
cutthroat and black and white you know
they've done some studies on this and
what one of the things that they I was
talking to Jordan Peterson about this
you know Jordan Peterson yes and he said
yeah you won't shut the [ __ ] my favorite
I kid he knows a lot about he's
professor of psychology and he said that
sometimes like so a racecar driver a guy
who takes risk a guy who might be a tier
1 commando and then you know somebody
like Andy stump our friend who does that
squirrels red roses there's certain
people that that can that really can
take risk and their heart rate doesn't
really raise a lot they actually said it
about sports science did a thing on
athletes where they measured like under
real duress like great yep great
pitchers and stuff yeah they don't
really they don't they're they don't
they don't choke the way all of them
experience it is but it's also a
personality type and one of the things
they say is that the same kind of thing
that allows those kind of guys to stay
calm under pressure it's kind of the
same trait that bank robbers have as
well so those kinds of people those
traits those traits sometimes if they
are if they are steered in the wrong
direction so to your point that's when
you they are not if they are not they're
not given the opportunity to be educated
not given the opportunity to see a path
they could they could legitimately be
CEO they'll do but here's the other
thing about it you know sometimes risk
the risk of it the the excitement the
juice I've taken a risky and be on the
outside and they probably have a little
bit of a sociopath everything works out
but the thing with El Chapo maybe think
about this was watching it and what put
the chip on his shoulder is his dad was
terrible and was like oh you're gonna be
a narco or whatever a cartel member you
never gonna be a boss you should be a
[ __ ] helper all your life yeah and
then he was always small right El Chapo
means short yeah so he was always really
tiny so he had like this chip on his
shoulder yeah I was like man I wonder if
you gave him the same opportunities that
saves a white kid went to Stanford or
Harvard I wonder if he would be like a
Steve Jobs type or is it just completely
different I don't know cuz my feeling is
that yes some some people who are
willing to kill that many people like
cuz it's an order of business this is
what's different they grow up in that
culture where that's that's its dip so
we didn't grow up like that's like oh my
god you would do that to them they're
like what do you mean like I don't think
it's how much this guy did I don't think
its culture I think it's people so I
think that there are a lot of people
obviously who grew up in Mexico who
would never kill I think that those are
very rare like what people are willing
but know a lot of people are probably
know I think it's rare but I think if
you're if you're exposed to that it's
different maybe like like like just for
instance we hang on to it no but that
may be but let's say I grew up in South
Central I mean Crenshaw and I grew up
with my friends dying shooting all this
gangbang all the time I'm a view the
world a little different so I've never
seen it like what shooting someone but
you know what happened oh man that's but
two things happened with that two things
happen with that either they they get
they try to get the [ __ ] out or they get
they they're going to avoidance they try
they try to avoid it or then conversely
there are dudes who go I don't want to
be a sucker and they get into it right
so they become a member of against the
only options but but they've done a lot
of like really interesting studies like
this book that's so fascinating it's a
famous book called on combat and on
killing you wrote two books the [ __ ]
forgot his name and he he did a
psychological profile on sort of the
guys in
combat that do most of the killing late
talking about sewing war yeah so when
you ever when you have a platoon you
know and like they don't want to say is
I'm like Vietnam World War two it wasn't
like a lot of dudes were like great it
like shooting people a lot of dudes
didn't but they were a couple guys that
were just amazing
they weren't killer they weren't like
sociopaths they were just bad ass
[ __ ] they were just like oh I gotta
kill somebody
alright and they just the job yeah some
dudes can do it other guys can't so I
just think sometimes it's like anything
else some people have a predilection for
risk-taking and they're willing to do
[ __ ] other people aren't yep you know to
get to the time yeah and I don't know
man I wonder if those kind of people are
all sociopaths or maybe they're just
they're they're just like I was I like
people products my kids but but this is
what I need to do right now
what's into that show on any called 60
days in I've heard of it David Grossman
that's never heard of 60 days in no so
it's people who go undercover and going
to jail like the hardest core jail
system and they're basically just
snitches so they go in there they try to
get in with the inmates and then they
try to figure out like how people are
smuggling drugs in what this is going on
and they report back like no one knows
that they're snitches so they farm
around and they think they all they
makes think they're going like on the
same thing but they're not these guys
kind of like snitches in prison but
they're there for 60 days there's one
guy there is flourishing he's a family
man once again the police academy and
all that so he wanted to see what's like
being on the other side so he's gone
then he's flourishing and everyone's
drawn to him just a night white guy red
beard really but he thought with the
black guys the Mexicans that he's just
cool and they told him like dude you
there everyone's starting to like you so
much you need to chill out because
they're starting to look for you for
advice and it's like a shot-caller like
you need to chill out so he gets them of
60 days Ennis I'm gonna do another thing
sweet like uh it's not the program he's
like I'd love just do another 60 and
really learn more so they have him go
through with a psychology see if he's
mentally okay they put him in there but
what's interesting is they what's that
your biggest takeaway he goes the
biggest takeaways so far and he's been
around
everyone they all he talks to everyone
he was biggest takeaway is I'm thinking
about my future as you know going the
police academy being a police officer in
my family they just think about tomorrow
yeah they're OP they just want to
survive and they think they're gonna die
in the street so they don't even
consider a future they don't consider a
career cuz they're like well you don't
have picked on I don't like of your
potential the way rossini the potential
cos only sees this horrible like poverty
all the time
he was it's a bummer because I'll be
talking about oh when I get I'm gonna do
this and this talk to him like dude I'm
trying to get out get this money figured
you know they don't ya think about the
next day never it's interesting I take
that's an interesting thing you see that
in a lot of subcultures prison you
actually said I'm porn I've talked to a
lot of porn directors who are like which
like most almost every woman that
they've ever been around is just
literally will never think about
anything more than the next time yeah
the next day yeah next takedown this guy
do you hear about that cop who got he
was a black cop who got arrested for
corruption and I think he'd put some
guys away under false testimony or
evidence okay so he was going to Angola
to the farm
you know Angola that's that's that's
that's a rough prison that's they call
that the farm and I think it's in
Orleans I mean I'm sorry in Louisiana
and it was called they did it they did a
[ __ ] they did a documentary on ya
Louisiana State Penitentiary
it's called I know it's called the farm
that shows that I'm talking about the
sea stays in is the main one in Atlanta
to carry on and well they they said
we're gonna have a party for him they
were getting ready to give him a party
okay means party in his ass that's
correct sir he was going ahead as a cob
and he knew he said it he goes I was
gonna get raped and then I was gonna get
killed so what he did was he goes well
looks like I'm not gonna beat this case
he packed a knapsack and just
disappeared in the woods and lived there
for 25 years type move I think we might
have talked about senior yeah they did a
thing I've seen it yeah he just any guys
claw right he came out he came out
everybody was like hey guys all the guys
who knew he's a cop forgot the gas him
back in like yeah yeah and he just kind
of came out and he was like
I don't think you have to go back in oh
you know what else I got balls deep into
over the break had finally had some time
off was the menendez trial oh yeah
so Amy it's on you can give now an
on-demand v is they just wrapped but
when you watch it dude
they got [ __ ] well do you know what
they guys got super screwed give us the
whole thing like the father was awful
awful wasn't it though he was terrible
yeah did you gotta watch this cuz I said
the same thing like elders just rude you
know why he got convicted right you know
how they got convicted don't you know
what they I do yeah after you when you
watch this yeah yeah so you know the the
first trial they went through it was a
hung jury yeah right and they played the
whole you know molestation rape the
father did caused this the mother was
awful they brought in 90 witnesses from
all the family and everyone goes yeah we
knew this was going on what the the
father who died his brother his sister
the mom's sister there we knew this was
going on it was out he was out he was at
his dad was at was raping what yeah they
all knew this well come on and aunts
uncles cousins nieces nephews everything
everyone's almost in tears go and I wish
we would have said something like you
want it you want to God cuz cuz they got
convicted because they reloaded the
shotgun apparently the other brother did
okay but so is a hung jury right hung
jury and then that District Attorney
goat in LA goes [ __ ] this cuz then
shortly after that the OJ Simpson trial
happened so that's a big egg on the face
from the district attorney all right so
then they redo the trial with the
Menendez brothers and they go oh guess
what the judges side just goes you can't
use any of the rape stuff as a defense
anymore you can't use that why
that's their state saying you can't do
it so they purposely set him up boys
were now they're both in prison for life
no no chance of parole because they're
because there is no way to prove that
this didn't help that's what the know
there was a million witnesses and their
words ways to prove it there's a million
but that judge goes [ __ ] these guys I
don't want to be responsible for this I
was only a fancy to when you date they
had other dead other judges and lawyers
on they go we've never heard of this
it's so [ __ ] up with aid they took
away the only defense so they just got
[ __ ] on when in the retrial of course
they got life so that's it they're in
there and for life yeah but it's crazy
cuz
called Eric tells all it's the first
time Erik Menendez Melendez Menendez
yeah it was 1990 by the way right yeah
but they didn't go to trial to 93 and
then after that didn't get committed to
97 with all the retrials appeals yeah
and last Nanto been 20 years
what's crazy is he yeah he I pick Eric
the brother is calling him from prison
talking about all this he is yeah he's
you just like yeah it's crazy look at
that they also look kind of evil which
I'm sure does not oh they do and there
were rich kids right mmm there are rich
kids but what what set him what set them
off obviously the abuse all the years
all that stuff so that's so true that's
true so he thought he was gonna get it
be like finally I'm getting away from my
dad going to UCLA and the a week before
his Liam's dad goes whoa whoa you're not
[ __ ] leaving and he was yeah I'm
gonna live in the dorms down there and
go to school you're gonna live here
still he's like no I'm not doing that
man and his dad basically beat him I
made him suck his dick what yeah it's
horrible [ __ ] it's horrible horrible
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] kidding and the the
the therapist that saw Eric and the
tennis coach that was with them for
years for like ten years and the
therapist who's with him for 10 years
goes we know for a fact that dad was
molesting okay here's the thing okay if
I fight me if I think that they're doing
that to a child I don't give a [ __ ] I'm
doing whatever I can like they must be
pulling around here's how I got them yes
it guess how they got caught guess how
these [ __ ] guys got so remember they
were looking for a killer in now they
didn't have a motive at the time right
they did they kind of suspect him guess
how they got caught they went to this
therapist this therapist had a sidepiece
he's banging his secretary the secretary
would listen in when Eric Melendez would
come in she heard him confess to the
murders she called the cops can I ask
you a question though is it possible
that they were setting all this up to
murder them well you know what I mean
for the money no because that's what
they said they said it doesn't make
sense because it's all these years it's
all these years all these years they
have just punishment like the dad was
awful cuz it guess what this is why they
did it this is a reason why they did I
know it sounded like I'm defending two
murders but when you hear they call the
details it's crazy if you got raped
three days before three days before then
the mom knew this [ __ ] the whole time
that the father was raping them three
days before the dad goes oh we got where
they go to Marina del Rey he go we're
gonna go on our boat and his brother and
lick each other oh they're gonna kill us
they're gonna kill you think kills
because the brothers told their cousin
and the dads like you told him he's like
alright alright he's gonna tell every
what's gonna get out so the dad takes
them on a boat and the brothers said
they just sat like like so scared at the
front about like they're gonna throw us
off they go in the middle of the ocean
but there's a they were two people that
they didn't expect to be on the boat so
they couldn't do it so they get back and
the brothers go they're gonna kill us we
got to figure something out to do see
when if a therapist is being told that
somebody is raping them if it's childish
that therapist is under obligation to
tell the police because it's a crime
correct
so did the therapist ever go to the cops
I don't know you gotta watch this it's
crazy but you watching that god they got
[ __ ] man now should they be in prison
because they killed the parents for sure
I don't think so you don't think so well
well okay let's let's say all the rape
and child molestations
and beatings and all that was real then
I think that they should walk free I
really believe that because because you
know I have no idea what that would be
like first of all second of all you've
ruined a huge part of that human being
well if you're if you're raping your own
child you're raping any child obviously
but think about the level of depravity
and evil to do that to a child right and
and all that goes with it all the the
the insane abuse you're killing their
spirit when you hear about this they go
you have died till they were like 1617
the DAO didn't force on the shower
together
and then they would have friends over
and then the dad would take the kids to
the room and they would go oh will be
out we'll be out in a second and then
the dad the mom would tell whoever
staying goes no matter what you hear in
that room you're not allowed to go in
there it's so exciting family members
and it's horrible that [ __ ] is the
craziest stuff I've ever heard it's if
that's what the faces like mad dude that
dad's a piece of [ __ ] I mean I don't
know man
you know and you know it's like when
women kill a man because he's been
abusing her for yeah
like an and she does it life in prison
that's what you don't know what it's
like you know I like being the craziness
the insanity you finally go get away
from me and you shoot guy I you know I
have sympathy for it yeah it's it's a
little stranger here the story you know
but watch it
what's your on Netflix Amy goddamn on
demand they just wrapped that there's a
five-part special I think it's our Andy
and so you watched all of it I watched
every bit of it so you went online and
went oh [ __ ] that dad so you've come out
of it I got screwed all the evidence I
did yeah I came out of it did they kill
officer they [ __ ] killed him did they
do it for money no they did it from all
the years of abuse and also the the
therapist of psychologists on there they
go well a few things that set the public
off and the media ran with it is after
the parents died they they bought like
nice clothes watches a Porsche stuff
like that and they said a lot of it is
they've been so like suppressed so
suppressed and they just they didn't
then get whether the doctor tyrants are
gone yeah the tyrants are gone they're
also 18 and 19
yeah and they go those at what them
doing that isn't the actions of someone
who commits killed their parents for
money because they were done for money
they realize how that would love it they
thought what they did was the right
thing yeah and then now they're trying
to deal with it anytime that you have
somebody over you like like they say
that you know I don't know the man but
it's interesting that was soon as Tiger
Woods dad died he started [ __ ] he
started I'm sure he was doing a lot of
them but he had to be perfect his whole
life they're like why is he having so
many girls that dudes had they'd be
perfect his whole life his dad made him
what he was
it's a lot of good that came with it but
also when you've got to be basically
when you have somebody lording over you
your whole life you're gonna let loose
oh so in this case they were both really
really good at tennis and their tennis
coach who started with him from the
beginning said I had to stop working on
them they go white goes because the dad
was so overbearing would yell at me and
yell at the kids forced the brothers
just hit a non [ __ ] stop they're like
they are exhausted man he goes I felt so
bad for him
yeah when here all the witnesses and
then you hear how it was the perfect
storm with the media Oh Jay Simpson the
LA district attorney offices being
[ __ ] [ __ ] on by OJ and then this
retrial they're like whoa whoa we're not
letting them escape to you this won't
look bad so they [ __ ] them that's my
bad I'm amazing yeah that's amazing that
they would do that let it add tyranny no
I guess we did it right when he was
raping him like in the act of rape then
they might have gotten off right because
they thought about the fence that
JonBenet Ramsey thing I've heard one of
the theories was that she walked in
while he was molesting her she threw
something at him and caught her in the
head like she went to this rain I mean
there's so many pisser stairs that I
don't know I don't either but there's
darkness and families there's some dark
[ __ ] that's what this thing was
saying like everyone has you know they
see their family as a secret but the
meléndez secrets really don't I mean a
secret like woke a secret like somebody
sneaks cigarettes here and there you
know I'm saying like a secret y'all was
thinking I really don't have this a
secret okay and you know it does it's
like it's like when you see a family I
was with my whole my extended family
they're so close they're all so close
that you can you can kind of go if if
like god forbid you find out that with
somebody in your tribe was doing
something that you had to out cuz you
you find out somebody's molesting a
child don't snitch I don't give a [ __ ] I
don't give a [ __ ] you have to yeah
that's not on you you goddamn right you
would and you know that's an interesting
thing because the people who are weaker
or people who are scared you'll blow up
you'll blow up the entire you might blow
up the whole economic thing you might
blow up everything and so they keep
quiet they could it's too much it's too
much to face it's just too much to face
because if you tell on him he's going to
jail for life that's the father of your
kids away you know whatever it might be
I don't know dude we're all like you
know dude if you have good parents if
you're brought in this world good
parents you you're lucky man hell yeah
like they were talking about the best
thing you can do to not get cancer is to
choose to have parents that don't have
cancer like like you know a lot of it's
just genetics
that's not their phone well it should be
there's nothing no but in other words
like just just it's luck of the draw
you have good parents that's a big step
up I gotta piss so hard let's go piss
his cry face is terrible there
all right that's a bad cry face see but
he wasn't sad about it
he wasn't it's okay we're sad they
weren't they were sad about they they go
once we did realize holy [ __ ] we killed
our parents as much as a monster he was
like we don't have parents anymore yeah
I don't know man and the mom they killed
the mom because she let it happen right
not the mom was just bad Lamont the mom
didn't never stick up from the mom treat
him like [ __ ] Mickey Rourke talked about
that make it work said his brother died
in his arms and he because she married
this brutal cop this stepson who was a
brutal son of a [ __ ] they were the best
that father who beat the [ __ ] out of
them and he never forgave his mom for
that and was an unapologetic you never
talk to her again crazy [ __ ] anyway
she's been deep guys 2018 bringing us
down man well pop it back up what do you
do over there near that's part of the
look like most chill relax New Year's
ever I don't even go out with my friends
no sale my mom and dad ate dinner okay
yeah but that's hard like crazy for the
Christmas thing you did with my friends
yeah your pardon at 40 years old all
right yeah we drink like crazy I'm still
recovering right now my entire family
drank a lot right yeah how about you I
was sick the whole [ __ ] time but I
never get sick I was sick for ten days I
was I'm still I'm like now coming out of
it he's crazy
I just got off a plane but I was like
what is going on with me
my dad would say that if you're sick the
alcohol fights it and then we'd have to
drink even more true but and I tried
that and I had the flu and I almost died
like god this [ __ ] was humbling I got
humbled by this virus you were scared
you actually released I got humble I
just got I gave up I was like I gotta i
gotta i got a viral rash i got all kinds
of i was [ __ ] up it was
weird man I and I plus you have to stay
away from your family when you're sick
like that the whole thing was isolating
that's a poem I wrote a lot well that's
a good part of it then yeah
but damn cuz I you know III try to fight
it I won't take any medicine I'm like
I'll just hack the [ __ ] up no it took me
my mother said hey you are on the verge
of getting pneumonia you got to get on
antibiotics do you normally take regular
medicines no not even like tahno I don't
get sick I mean like headaches and upset
stomach
no no you just let it happen no I'm good
I'm usually good you know but this thing
I don't know I just I know exactly why
it happened to I was like I think I'm
getting sick why don't I do this I'll
sleep for hours and I'll work out twice
and then I'll I'll interview Jordan
Peterson on my mixed mental arts podcast
which I'm dropping on Friday everybody
and see I'm [ __ ] great conversation
but yeah and I just got I started
coughing and I went oh and when I did
Rogan I was hurtin but I got some
medicine I took dayquil and then it was
cool but did you downhill from there
ladies and gentlemen let's get it let's
get to it you shut the [ __ ] up ah don't
let's go for it by the way let's talk
about the fights no let's talk more
about the meléndez brother [ __ ] dick
I thought the fights bad that's a
battery I'm banged up my dog dude my
Invisalign I couldn't wear for the past
10 days yes
don't [ __ ] you happy which one the Corgi
yeah yes I'm Gorga a quarter I like Hong
Kong Oh Corey oh boy what was I gonna
say I fight you watched him in Mex yeah
I did not see I only saw the highlights
of the homes cyborg fight so you didn't
watch it I watched everything else
except with you left during the main
event and I found most of the [ __ ] yeah
I had a lot I had to you know happen
I'll tell you why we stopped you you
legally screamed it again I sure didn't
you did I'll tell you what happened you
did the game they'll not leave Miami
game of the Miami you gonna be home time
the Miami game is over
okay am i my dad remember long let's get
out of here I was like bye
it and I had to leave you went but the
main events up yeah
what were your favorite fights I thought
most of them and I'm gonna be honest
with you artwork total [ __ ] snooze
they're boring it's [ __ ] boring he's
[ __ ] me I know it's like well you know
and I took me a day and it hurts me
because I have people over for the
fights how you like to watch them by
myself but Todd came over my dad my
stepmoms they're Joe's they're her
friends are there I wear all these this
food and it's a good time and they're
not really into the fights Todd it's hot
bet on it I made him some Bangkok minor
dog big anyways
so but when it's a boring night oh my
god oh my dad went outside turned in the
middle of the main event I go dad what
are you doing dude what do you mean if
any yeah I don't know where [ __ ]
yeah if they're good fights even if
you're not a real avid fan you can still
get into I have a question a were
[ __ ] snoozy they were snoozy and you
know everything it's not it's not ufc's
fault listen UFC paper either like
starburst they can all be read and no I
can't sometimes get yellows and oranges
but I I've always had Carlos Condit in
my top three welterweight its all-time
in a lot of ways I just think he's so
[ __ ] good
well here's Michael Magni here's my
question I found and we talked about
this he's got a lot of wear and tear on
him I've never seen Carlos Condit kick
and get his foot caught that many
[ __ ] time heals very good that's fine
I've never seen a badger Carlos - why
because there's a height and cardio Neil
Neil just sees he's damn near impossible
knockout he's long he's athletic he
doesn't he's gonna doesn't care about
being you know yeah take you down over
and over yeah you don't take a lot of
risks I'm surprised had so long off
thought about retirement yeah Matt heals
not he just you know the only time Neil
loses is if the guys world-class
jiu-jitsu so he lost at dos Anjos Demian
Maia and that other [ __ ] in
Brazil who trying with the [ __ ] out
other than that he's beat Kelvin
Gastelum Johny Hendricks Hector Lombard
like everybody else Carlos Condit beats
everybody else as long as you're not
world class I found Carlos to be a step
slow I really did I think he was fast
I think it's a I think it's a number of
things I think a he probably should stop
he's talked about stuff and he won't you
talk about it's over yeah when you
already have one foot out it's all about
time is not in the top 15 just can't
compete yeah and so I think it's a bad
match Carlos go to one of my favorite
piece of all time I think the matter of
the matchup was bad and he doesn't want
these full hearts on it that's right
then you get this [ __ ] that's what I got
does it happen I got that his heart
boring [ __ ] oh yeah boring final got out
and I love Neil I was I watched I was
like you know it's just I'm just bored
and I'm so bored I can't remember any of
the fight ah then there's a cavia and
Esparza
which I also called yeah underdog yeah
yeah I just thought the spars that she
didn't tell she the UFC kind of shuns
her throws her under the lights like she
was your first champ don't cheer like
[ __ ] she beat Rose yeah she had some
time off and kuvira she's amazing she's
amazing and the UFC has this rocket on
her she's gonna be a star but the world
doesn't work like that she really hasn't
beat anyone who's world class she's just
not that's as far as us too much too
soon for her yeah shoot that was a bad
idea a good gave her a good fight to
lost that fight and then she freaked out
you see her freaked out at the end yeah
which I wait I like the past and people
don't be a sore loser
I like the past I like the passion Chris
she lost she wants to win yeah that's
when you know a fighter is gonna get
better because they want to win so badly
then they die when they see me fine yeah
she's and then what other fights can
have on them bring that up to oh and
then you got Dan hooker Marc dear Casey
was boring as [ __ ] boring to be bet at
the barbozza yeah yeah I wasn't the most
entertaining it just could be beaten the
[ __ ] at a bar bowling just closed and
like almost like like I found it amazing
that he was just he just kept pressing
and by the way walking in with his hands
down a lot of times which I was amazed
at he just closed the distance that he
just gave up gym pressure and then just
takes the legs every table needs your
legs and he just takes your legs he does
this thing where he just I cut you down
Kabira is the absolute nightmare he'd be
a nightmare to fight he I think he
especially at 55 if you have 55 or 70
he's the worst match
for anybody pause for anybody who's at
night because it's torture like I
tweeted out I said man I'd much rather
just get murked by Francis than fight
could be this is you bebe wait you just
he just he's on top of you torture and
no one can get him off no one not the
best in the world can't do end of a hand
they say he's never lost around in
practice he's never lost around in
professional fighting he's never lost
around in sorrow sick they say he gives
Luke Rockhold dcj baskets all they can
handle
that's Gremory smart them has never lost
around any of those [ __ ] crazy
but you and I'm on this khabib train I
think abhi was amazing he just needs to
fight more he'll be a superstar he's the
only thing you need to fight more but
beating Edson Barboza Barboza's good I
think
Barbosa is a little overhyped name the
best guy Barboza's beat whenever he's
faced like the tip of the spear he's
lost every fight but he beat baby cowboy
no no that would be on camera beat him
that's right he was beating he was
giving it to a cowboy and then in the
lost but anytime he's faced like the
upper upper echelon guys he's lost
it's the perfect fight for Kebede
because because that's a huge take yeah
yeah well you all that's in it oh yeah
it's and dozens of strikes so it could
be so it's a good win but it's not you
know I don't know yeah I thought you
looked great and foot I don't know who's
gonna beat could be I think it with
khabib Conor and Tony Thurston it's a
rotating door one matches up with one
great one matches one better than the
other match it but it's all just a pair
so so your your Colin I think khabib is
just too much for Conor in terms of
Connors better striker and that's all
great but you know if you don't if you
don't catch him as he walks in with you
you're getting taken down and it's a
disaster the thing of that I'd like to
see is if Connor could weather that
storm and you go in those fourth and
fifth round but how do you have seen
heavy weather how do you weather khabib
he's not rising you just like get some
digital rides you don't think Connors
dry on the island Barboza you try to
stand up keep trying to stand up Barboza
last of all five rounds yeah that's true
I'm sorry all three rounds yeah yeah
thank God third years
honey by the way by the way that's when
you have khabib on you for three rounds
let's see how you do on the fourth and
fifth like you you gotta have you have
to be Bing you got somebody's got a
blood dope you right there on the fourth
round I don't think anybody can deal
with it I really don't I don't know how
you deal with a guy who's wearing you
like a sweater the whole [ __ ] time
khabib wolves I'll tell you who could
deal with this Tony Ferguson he's better
cardio and if you take him down it's no
picnic that's what I wanna watch elbows
triangles his guards nasty he's longer
he's very good off his back he's very
good but see so I think Tony matches up
really well khabib I think Conner
matches up well with Tony I think it's a
rotating really I think Abby's the
toughest guy to beat out of all of them
I think there's percentages Gibbs at the
top that he'll it's G's gonna be a
nightmare to beat you got to hopefully
catch him percentage captain's not good
and then Tony and Connor have their
holes but when they match up it's not a
bad matchup for Conor yeah
either way you explained though I I know
it's probably impossible but I don't I
don't like this is one of those amazing
things with khabib where I don't see
what he's doing but obviously he's doing
everything like I can't see it I can
just see him like he's he's got he's
grabbing your legs he's riding eyes
which are watching underhood it's over
any other hood it's underhook Cesaro in
Samba scissors to an end Greco right is
that what a Samba you're not it's just
the best there's just a thousand things
he does when he went against who's the
wrestler
hold on it'll come to me he's an na a
world champion
I'm sorry national champion he shot on
him 24 times took him down 21 times and
he was NAIA national champ wait wait
wait trio able able tree hold was at
NAIA national champ when to be fought
him in the UFC he took him down ready 21
times I like the guys never even seen a
wrestling he can't take it he's like oh
all American wrestling all very cool I'm
gonna shoot 24 times takedown 21 times
the most ever unless he's from Dagestan
Sara's [ __ ] either by Jean Dagestan
Armenia that whole area
Iran Turkey they just wrestle I would a
lot and see I thought obviously you can
be pets and use my lock on the
if you can put your money on anyone put
on could be even that fight supplies but
I think you know khabib 's biggest
opportunity it was what was he gonna do
it we knew he's gonna win was he doing
the mic afterwards he didn't rip the
greatest promo it's really not his thing
but I wish they would had something
prepared I wish DC can I help them or
someone from a kid could help them with
that now do we see Tony could be but do
we see it's all uncut just depends what
Connor wants to you know Connor and
Kitty were talking [ __ ] on Twitter and
Connor goes dude I need people to get on
a knee and you know beg me to fight he
goes cuz my whiskey's coming out next
month and that's dating money yourself
to fight you I need a legit you know so
it's really up to UFC coming to terms
with Connor to make it worth his while
then I don't think I mean I think Connor
would what Connor would do that you're
not gonna see Connor could be next
you're gonna see Connor Tony exit Tony
has the belt so I'm not gonna fight
could be just a [ __ ] fight them
you see Connor Tony first if if Connor
is gonna fight if not you got Tony to be
which I'll [ __ ] take off I'll take
that all day that's amazing Jesus
but caller needs to figure out we can do
so that division can move on you can't
have this in there because what's next
for khabib is either Tony or Connor or
Nord you don't fight anyone else just
wait for that but yeah it's a fight you
know Kabhi needs to fight yeah but I
mean can we just please can we have just
an interim championship belt it's not
how the Connors doing heavily I know but
hey Connor Daniel right well yeah I
don't know I don't know what you do it
you make you make you make that you make
the Ferguson could be a fight you just
do it right they tried before they've
been trying to do it you know make
weight well yeah when I'm worried about
that but you just got a you know yeah
yeah super fresh and then cyborg Holly
Holm yeah all he lasted all five rounds
I saw just the I want to get your take
because I saw I saw the you know
highlights and she was giving her the
what for but sheshe kind of I was
surprised at some of the comments online
where people thought Holly was doing
better I thought Holly she wasn't
putting combos together great and her
sticking move was kind of working
Chris I've worked so good man she's just
so good they would they would exchange
shots and Chris just hit so much harder
so Hollywood where it and when Hollywood
land Chris would just walk through it
she's bigger she's not she's just she's
a better striker better she's just
better and you know I just thought Chris
came I like a storm just no one's really
in her no one's in there there's no one
close yet the only fight really I was
making Anderson the blob what about that
she's a big cow man Megan no one's
beating cyborg nobody's beating it's not
being sorry about the bummer is Holly
Holmes team or something went on social
mediums like in trance yeah I mean show
a little class come on guys I like the
dance Ronnie was like I've been training
with him forever I don't I don't support
that [ __ ] he tweeted that that's just
some [ __ ] two runs their social
meetings a photographer just some dumb
ass and then they tried to fend him they
going all well in the locker room they
were laughing at Holly from a picture on
the bus yeah you know Chris I was
somebody worthy of a great deal of
respect hold on she's the greatest
female fighter of all time yeah how
about a little funny someone better
correct game someone better correct she
she's the greatest female fighter about
thought people want to believe yo it's
all because she's a dude or doesn't work
that you knows don't work I know
well steroids and women's different the
men's stop all that will you watch
announcer over in fight we watch a Vitor
Belfort fight pretty watch Amy John
Jones we watch any of these guys who
have been bust before and do you boo
them when they walk out exactly pd's
RPGs will change your dynamic you don't
think it changed oscar Overeem's
dynamics you don't think he's been on
more [ __ ] gear than [ __ ] any
average jug Gold's Gym your honor if you
don't think it changed his DNA and his
structure 100% oh well it's going well
she's been tested more any female
fighter on the roster and it seems we
pass it it was one because she has a
very strong social is like pay transit
she don't look like Rhonda okay that's
fine
well guess what she doesn't look like
them and guess what she's the best
female fighter on the plant is awesome
why do you think that here she works her
ass off you know and she I don't get the
hate I thought Holly did great
I I gave her maybe one round two if I
mean super [ __ ] friendly
I love Holly but maybe one round but
Chris looked amazing man 2 good amazing
and different to like I from what I saw
she looked like she wasn't beeline and
she was kind of like I told ya I told
you she was into it she don't fight like
that anymore man I'm sure that new Pro
her boxing coach is a wizard I think
he's the best in the game they noticed
too in the fifth round not tired in the
least bit no you want to go five ramp
cyborg you enjoy this God you look great
men her the head kick was there for her
she was laying it
it was nice Holly you know it's just is
she's never gonna beat Chris cyborg
anyone out there I don't know what they
do with her I really don't I am Anna
Nunez Tom out she wants the winner I
would love a super fight I'm in a
newness cyborg be a man that would be
pretty wild man he's a badass but but
she's a big gal she probably walks at
what ones not like 5 borden she's not
the same structure aside well she ain't
happy to have some trouble she can throw
that I love a man in it as do i I love
to fight no huh you say no I'd like to
see to beef cyborg that's what I'd like
to see I don't know what you do with her
I don't know it's gonna be tough cuz
she's so much better than everyone you
just have her fight Holly like every
other weekend like it's [ __ ]
Arlovski Tim say what do you do there's
no one in that division you got to grow
it so who knows I'm sure Sona step up
some pourcel I think we'll look back on
cyborgs and feel that she was treated
very unfairly well think about it you
know in this is all in the past I hate
bringing up old [ __ ] why bring up old
[ __ ] Brennan but you know when cyborg
was doing her thing and Dana goes oh
she's Wanderlei Silva with braids like
that narrative when that goes to the
mass ISM and people go oh we can't [ __ ]
on her look at her her boss is doing it
yeah okay makes her feel like physics to
think so when she was on here on my show
the big run but she's in tears yeah
really yes she goes I just wanna be
treated fair man yeah what is it she
just wants to be feel remember shot of
her face you know her she is a girl man
she's a female she's a woman and she's
that stuff [ __ ] yeah yeah that's like
so so when Dana says that stuff I know
it's in the past and he's apologizing
he's obviously moved on and she's the
world champion now
but when the head guy goes hope it's
free range on cyborg go ahead fellas
well then you get the internet trolls
remember negativity loves company so
they all jump on board together because
all their life suck so then they direct
that cyborg and instead of looking to
worked out further though did effort it
takes to be that guess worked out for
you but yeah overall the card I thought
snooze hasten news you didn't get a
yellow starburst every element yeah what
do you think of a Holly's this is the
first time I really noticed her yelling
when she punches and everything but this
time it seemed like goes overboard like
really she's trying to make up for the
hits by the sounds no that's how I
thought we're just shy like tennis
players we're breathing right my god I
hear I see that with a lot of Bob she
wasn't putting a lot of Kumble me I'm
super silent when I fight oh here we go
I'm silent would you sit for New Year's
Jim for dudes
I'll answer um had dinner with his
parents I did that earlier I did nothing
I cause remember the Christmas thing I
went like overboard
we had a crapload of friends over we did
a slumber party thing so New Year's you
say they're your parents
yeah it's number oh yeah you just had
dinner I was a pajama party party you
guys got on your PMS was there any did
anybody free their dick
no no one free any girls was at all guys
did you invite it was actually girls her
man you invited him it was that okay the
girl that we know that's her house it
was her most Koreans Vietnamese my
friends are mostly Vietnamese
interesting mm-hmm alright so and then
just had my parents did you watch the
ball drop
no I've I slept at like nine now she got
woke up by the fireworks you were in bed
by nine
yeah Jesus Christ I partied too hard
during the other one oh I did I would uh
I know I'm just glad to be back in that
way dude I bet I really am I'm glad to
be back to work man I mean I love the
time off is nice but oh you guys had
time off I I was on my back alright
let's go to Carter
the first one is a about a guy named
Logan Paul if you know him he's like
super huge on YouTube his brothers Jake
Paul he has an enormous following on
YouTube and he did this video where he
was going to that suicide forest in
Japan I'm sure of it
I've heard of before what's the
background on it Jin for some reason a
lot of younger people that commit
suicide go to this particular area of
Japan so it's called like the dark phone
called the suicide forest oh wow so he
went there on his YouTube world he wants
to film on his YouTube channels saying
like if there's any spirits or ghosts or
anything there yeah just mess around
he's messing around and they saw
personality yeah they saw actual dead
body it was an actual dead body watch
the video to drive do you have the video
here if you guys wanna see the problem
with MCS was just so privacy yeah he's
an entertainer and he came there to look
for spirits like right he's a youtuber
he's [ __ ] you know yeah he's trying
to make entertainment I know you got a
sense of humor no watches I don't I
watched I was like god this guy [ __ ]
up cuz see they're not freaking out so
he said he didn't monetize this video
cuz the suicide is not a joke he
actually put this on his do you think
that's real
other Hangul okay a lot of things go
through my mind um you tell you the
effective the first for me this list
literally probably just happened um just
so she you call the police this is hands
are purple you did this this morning you
know it shows his face
I'm so sorry about this Logan this was
supposed to be fun vlog suicide is not a
joke
depression and mental illnesses I'm not
a joke in no way we came here with a
sidekick in the back
[Music]
this just became very real and obviously
a lot of people he's a young guy doesn't
know how to deal with something very
epic joke now when you keep going
there's party I'm laughing but you can
tell he's uncomfortable yeah like he go
happy goes what tough so I know he's
trying to look I don't get my second
flack the most real vlog I've ever made
400-plus blogs and I've never I've never
had a more real moment than this yeah he
have initially he's a young guy at all
yeah I I don't because I he's a young
guy
what did I think I think I think there's
somebody dead there and he was he was
what happened afterwards was he was
trying to make it a little bit funny not
really I feel like it's like what the
[ __ ] that I can see people like come now
and look there's you gotta be there's a
silence there's a reverence there's a
there's a respect for the dead and and
the debt I and I know why and heap
apologize because I think he probably
watched it and went oh [ __ ] you know but
he's not a bad guy I don't see I don't
see he reacted and the way a lot I
didn't watch
and go oh my god he's in maturity I I
feel like we probably react this about
like oh [ __ ] yeah this is crazy and then
after you know you get over that high
emotional state you're like what the
[ __ ]
we came out of the Dead Guy back there
no I think sometimes people would rather
you step off you know you you go there's
a dead body we're just gonna you know oh
yeah yeah yeah when you have 17 Miller
where the [ __ ] he has you're an
entertainer shooting vlogs you're going
this haunted forest there's a dead dude
no my goal let's not show it's so sad to
see that guy there god dammit
it's like terrible Hawk and and Japan
has always had a tradition of like
suicide like the samurai work I don't
have a problem this Logan Paul guy I
don't know him I've never seen this
stuff no I don't know I saw online I go
crazy I'm a frog I don't think him being
young is anything to it I don't think he
did anything distaste he's not a bad guy
he's just no he's just kind of yeah he
look you know what happened he was doing
his thing and he ran into something
insane he was like what the [ __ ] is
going on I would love to know how anyone
who has any sort of fallen or anyone in
general if you're on Instagram live or
whatever Facebook live and you encounter
the idea how would you realize there are
a lot of people the idea would be and
there's an argument to make you don't
show a picture of the body cuz you don't
know who that body belongs show the
faith yeah insert there could be anybody
and and then you don't you don't sit
around and kind of like I think you see
both sides don't you like you know I
don't I don't well they shouldn't I
don't you I can see people go God dude
just move do and shut move on yeah I
don't see the uproar I don't see people
be like oh you should be taken off
youtube calm down oh that's great he
shouldn't lose all the stuff you work
for no dead bodies very uncomfortable
around that stuff and they're gonna
react people don't even know their own
reaction like people he didn't he didn't
know how to react and I think a lot of
people that see that done that or react
to what they do is they date they also
have a moment they it's very death like
that suicide is very very disconcerting
man it's it it [ __ ] people up a lot
sometimes they have a family member that
did it then then they get that hits a
bunch of triggers so respect like that's
factors for both sides respect so they
probably just didn't want him to show
the body yeah
and talking about it in front of the
bodies has if it's someone's you know
son or whatever I get that I get that
but you can't see anything yeah I know
but it's still an actual human being
that is someone that is someone's son
that is someone's brother so if they
know that's the person that I think I
was laughing even though it was a
nervous laugh I totally get that -
laughing that that can set that can
trigger people it just can and you know
I don't think you should be disciplined
or shunned for not any apologize no you
didn't monetize it wasn't to get money I
don't think and I think he gets it
you know you apologize he gets it you
like he got he got it twenty-two years
old yeah do that thirty-four fine
counter dead by bike oh [ __ ]
I'd freak out but there's no way we
would put it on the show here how crazy
is that
oh my let's make all blurs you're
walking through the woods and you see
you see somebody hanging [ __ ]
yeah you don't know what you're gonna
react you know how you gonna react when
I'm not gonna take out my phone yell
worldstar teen suicide we all started
epidemic apparently in this country I
don't get it since 2305 bodies were
found in the forest
what man that's where people go why that
forest 105 document suicides a year Wow
it's just a cool place to do it I don't
know why other people do it well wasn't
going Gate Bridge in America number one
on a long time Golden Gate and then SS
part that documentary the bridge as this
park is big in Denver I mean how many
people would jump was he 24 a year for
Cisco yeah
Golden Gate Bridge the bad it was more I
think a long fall you know think about
it yeah that woman all those stories
like that suicides 19 oh my no 300k 1937
to 2012 estimated 1600 bodies recovered
of people have jumped from that bridge
oh it's a lot old on 60 on our bodies
from nineteen thirty seven thousand
thirteen
haribol 2013 118 potential jumpers were
taken down in their attempt and did not
jump about 5% of the jumpers survived
the initial impact but generally drowned
or died or hypothermia on the cold water
Wow hidden water I sent my mom now talk
to somebody guys she's got real dark
yeah definitely
let's see good looking kid there's John
Kerry Underwood she had an accident at
her home last November I near home we
had a concert at her home
[ __ ] so she she said that she only like
broke her wrist and didn't really see
much else but she hasn't shown her face
since and she apparently she had 40 to
50 stitches on her face and she's
letting her fans know through her
website that when she comes back on
camera when you see her again she might
look a bit different what did she do
that fellas that need for I guess into
glass probably fought fell down the
stairs
dude this guy told me that his friend
they were on a fishing trip and his
buddy walked through a glass thing on
the yacht Oh his face came off oh
[ __ ] face came off and he's like dude
to come my friend had never faced I was
like well I don't know what that means
yeah so good so at 40 50 stitches I mean
you must face some serious [ __ ] I would
imagine hopefully she's alright she's
gorgeous that Demi selfie is very hot
that's a bummer you know what that glass
thing you're talking about I'm sure you
guys already know to be super careful
are on glass but I saw that there's a TV
show back in the days it was like
emergency room or something like that
well it was actual footage of people and
I guess those guys that carry those
windows like on their arms yeah he
slipped and then fell and then his face
got sliced the way you said it was but
just all the way through here yeah and
then they show the image of the guy's
face so straight down the middle yeah
and it was like you know one part was
above or one part was below he's died he
was he was alive and they found pimp
cream in his pocket so they knew he was
already self-conscious about you know
pimples and stuff yeah
your half face way healthier now that I
know I do
they said it's basically your Winston
Churchill he's like she was like doing
this in Parliament or something you know
yeah and she goes mr. Churchill this
this MP goes when mr. Churchill
you are drunk and he goes and you madam
are ugly and tomorrow I will be sober
that's all there's no that's a bummer
filling its face just be careful on
glass it's so simple even when you're
carrying a little piece of time down
glass you [ __ ] knows I'm in a face mask
okay you know what swatting is swatting
swatting when someone calls in a fake
like emergency like like a murder or
hostages or you know bombs okay just so
they can see you like a SWAT team or
police go to a place it's a weird thing
that people have never heard of it
it happened in Kansas right now and the
guy that answered the door was a father
and the police shot him dead because he
reached for his waistband he had no idea
what's going on so the guy that called
it in was in Los Angeles and this guy
was in Kansas and he said that oh I just
killed my dad I'm holding my kids
hostage come now I'm gonna put gasoline
on the house to burn it up too so that's
all the police had to go on and when
they showed up they said get out of the
house the guy walked out didn't know I
was going on and I guess he reached for
his waistband and then the cop kills the
darkest show ever dude this is my show
this is the prankster guys welcome 18
this the prankster and he's done stuff
like this before well I called in a bomb
threat before he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
so you go to prison for a murder that's
something about murder but something
he's a [ __ ] and then on the New York
Times they're saying like who's
responsible I mean should the cops have
killed them this guy like how much
blamed the the cops have on this not
sure well
hey man you guys started next one I love
kids let's just make this the dark show
you know what dark dark oh you guys
thank you thing this is called the [ __ ]
you show it's super dark I'm gonna make
it more your life now we go chin okay so
Christie Chrissy Teigen yeah I guess
there's like a conspiracy theorist girl
on Twitter who has like over 50,000
followers she was 40,000 over 50,000
followers she was would he call that one
you have the check mark no she's out or
something like that verified verified so
she's verified and then she was making
all these claims that Chrissy Teigen and
John Legend are a part of a pedo ring
and they're they actually put their
daughter up as one of the things from
okay
and when Chrissy Teigen actually
responded to this no because she's
verified she was pissed off well how is
woman verified and she could say this
stuff so she wanted you know she talked
smack on Twitter and to people that
followed her and she even posted this
stuff on her her own Twitter because she
was gonna ignore it in the beginning but
now she's trying to take this girl down
period she's trying to sue this girl
whoever posted this stuff and then
Twitter followed up by taking the verify
tag off that move god what a [ __ ] just
because she used a pizza emoji and then
I guess when they dressed the daughter
up in certain little outfits
it's supposed to be signals or signs
people are idiots for sure find
something better to do with your life
but she's gonna take her down now so she
said this is the first like real move to
take someone like this out good to like
okay this is nothing I didn't do a
credit mess but I saw this I thought
this is cool
birdies like giant don't tell me well
it's causing this giant trevally are we
gonna get flag to this I'm gonna put it
[ __ ] I'm gonna just show man it last
time they freaked out
I didn't know this existed yeah man
so there's fish just attacking birds
that are sitting in the ocean but that's
cool check this out yeah the birds back
is all yeah so check this out
the birds flying all right the jumping
they're shooting out drink on the wing
I'm just going a little slurpy slurp how
could I didn't not know this is possible
watch they do look honest look like
mister look like these
I mean well he just missed so there is a
fish here that amazingly has a brain
he's aggressive calculating the airspeed
altitude I'd like to hit that fish over
the head and eat him but check this out
oh oh my lord
[Music]
they're like little great whites but
stupid
malicious feathers are great down there
bro enjoy that beak [ __ ] you just got a
duh yeah I thought that was pretty cool
it's called it giant Rizal it's pretty
glad you showed me that yeah do you guys
like thank you showing us birds dying he
shead a dark chin do you guys like
Cloverfield yeah
Cloverfield there's a part 3 coming out
and there's zero information on it only
coming out next mile miss that what was
the first two the first one was in in
New York called a monster in New York
yeah and then he was like one was with
John Goodman yeah down I like that via
sails look really but I like you too and
what else you got in fact Apple is gonna
replace old iPhone batteries for $29
after ever since that one thing happened
where they are slowing down the phones I
blasted it out oh I like that because
you know your phone slows down Apple a
new thing that's really angry yeah yeah
no $29 you're a new phone six only
reason why your phone slows down it
bothers me no I will go hey there's my
my battery replace box check this out by
2050 chocolate could be gone
[ __ ] a corn wha uh her shopping
Wow hipper Cadbury bakes the differ Mars
candy company is partnered with the
University of trying to save cocoa
plants hold on I'll buy it
[ __ ] off no chocolate for life chocolate
for life throw
god that's a rib there's a real bummer
is that it child that's the end that's
right what do you say oh there's one
more Dana why he said Conor McGregor
wants to rematch with Mayweather oh come
on not real
he said he wants it badly this is Conor
was fight again really bad once that
fight again really bad on fs1 last week
I told Connor we did was amazing I was
in there was my partner in Lorenzo kept
saying oh my god we found this kid in
Ireland for years ago he's going to the
sixth round with Floyd
whether he's going to seventh round with
for another he's extremely well but
Connor was not happy with his
performance obviously Connor truly
believed he was going to win that fight
McGregor did all right white goes on say
I thought kind of won the first four
rounds preach got understand I did every
show on earth no expert said countered
land a punch I get all that and it says
I know deep down he'd do that fight
again but he needs to get back to MMA
and when it's time again get back there
my main yeah I don't want to see that
again I can get you back to MMA
that's it well buddy any more negative
[ __ ] Jen
no this was the dark side let's go eat
too and 18s getting dark you're starving
I can't wait to get out of here that's
why I'm not playing I hear you man
should I eat that I wouldn't you and I
are you allowed to eat chocolate
nope definitely Aikido is that to be
dark dark cocoa
80 or 90 percent cocoa spicy black chalk
yes on it yeah you can [ __ ] off with
that 90 percent [ __ ] yeah it's just -
I'll go 72% that's as high as I'll go
I agree 72 anything [ __ ] [ __ ] bitter
yeah
ain't shocked yeah all right sunshine
first wanted on 18 man hey guys which
ended my dates Nashville Nashville
January 12 13 14 and you mean Columbus
Ohio
I got comas Ohio you you bastards 25 26
27
funny bone I got I got Washington DC
February 1 2 & 3 I said it DC improv all
right
that's right I'm announcing it you lose
our favorite club is the 930 Club in DC
oh that's a good love that place
Scott God these she has really changed
I actually it'll be a little cold on Feb
2 in Feb 1 & 2 ah let's see we're all
Portland next weekend 11th through the
13th I'm at the helium in Portland
bosses sold out in the 19th and then
February 1st I'm in Denver at the Comedy
Works downtown 2nd 3rd I'm at the helium
in st. Louis get your tickets now t fat
k calm also tomorrow 5:00 p.m. Pacific
we're dropping the
original advocating Fight Club hoodies
in a new color combo and beavis and
butt-head inspired MTV find the kid tees
get them tomorrow 5:00 p.m. Pacific
only at tea fat K calm for tickets for
Brian in myself t FF k calm thank you
for listening happy new you have an air
filthy animals this is the fine kid
we're out